foreign  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  I'm really blunt because you know I like  it when underdogs like mixed Rises Korea  Japan and uh just this is like this  world cup is crazy a lot of like  underdogs are doing well and this is  what brings us together this is the  World Cup  they have a skier and a tactic I think  Japanese Samurai Street so yeah team is  stronger  [Music]  I think with this type of performance we  can be Brazil and go all the way to what  semi-final finals win the World Cup yes  uh  uh  koreabita absolutely Brazil this is a  good opportunity for the Japanese people  to improve the soccer quality and Osaka  culture  [Applause]